[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Invented in
the early 19th century
by a Scottish scientist
studying light,
the kaleidoscope
can still compete
when it comes to producing
stunning visual effects.
Peer inside and witness dazzling
geometric images produced
as mirrors multiply objects.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The images are
spectacular and fleeting,
each one lasting just seconds
before the next appears.
Many years after its
invention, the kaleidoscope
is still worth looking into.
To make a kaleidoscope,
this craftsman
starts with the mirror sheet
that has adhesive backing.
He scores it to create
long and narrow rectangles
and gently breaks it
along the scored lines.
The mirror's reflective
coating is on the front
instead of the underside.
A mirror like this produces
sharper reflections
than a regular household mirror.
He slices the adhesive
backing to separate
the mirrored rectangles.
He snaps off the
scored ends, creating
perfectly linear edges.
Next, he peels backing
from a strip of blackout
felt paper and wraps it
around a glass rectangle.
This felt wrapped glass
will be the third wall
of the two mirror system,
one with a triangular
configuration.
He removes the adhesive
film from the mirrors,
then builds the triangles
with the mirror's
reflective surfaces
facing inward
towards the
felt-wrapped rectangle.
This arrangement
will reflect objects
to create a circular
image known as a mandala.
He aims the mirrors
system at a light box
with a two line drawing in it.
One line is curved and
the other is straight.
Peering into it, he adjust
the alignment of the mirrors
until the lines morph
into a five point star.
This means the corners
of the mirror triangle
are precisely 36
degrees and it is
multiplying images correctly.
He hot glues the mirrors
to the opaque part
and applies metal
tape to the top
seem to complete the
kaleidoscope mirror system.
Over in the art
department, the artist
assembles decorative objects
against a black background
and an acrylic cell.
With every placement, she
checks the effect through
the triangular mirror system.
She glues dichroic
glass onto the backdrop.
It's a kind of glass that's
been treated with metal oxides
and it appears to
have different hues.
Other objects include
jewelry parts, colored wire,
buttons, and even paper clips.
She follows no specific
design but works free style.
While she glues some
down, she leaves others
loose to simply tumble around.
A sprinkle of tiny beads
completes the grouping.
As the mirror system
multiplies these objects,
they will create the mandalas.
These are photographs
of actual mandalas,
and they'll be used to
decorate the outside
of the kaleidoscope.
The other member of
the team now applies
an acrylic adhesive
to the rim of the cell
and presses a clear lid onto it.
The lid fuses to the
cell body, but it's
not yet completely sealed.
There's a tiny hole in
the side of the cell
through which he now
dispenses heavy mineral oil.
Submerged in mineral
oil, the objects
will float and move through
the cell for greater effect.
He plugs the hole with an
acrylic adhesive and screw.
He is now ready to assemble all
the parts of the kaleidoscope.
He slides the mirror system
into a heavy cardboard
tube decorated by
the mandala photos.
He cushions the mirror
system with foam,
and this stabilizes it.
He installs a metal eyepiece
and glass lands on one
end of the kaleidoscope too.
He slides the object cell
into a protective metal
cage that rotates.
He places a transparent
glass disk over the cell.
He applies adhesive to
the cage and inserts
the assembly into the other
end of the kaleidoscope tube.
This kaleidoscope is
now ready for a viewing.
Light passes through
the object cell,
illuminating the trinkets.
Reflections bounce
off the mirrors
to create one spectacular
illusion after another.
Two centuries after
its invention,
the view through the
kaleidoscope still fascinates.
[MUSIC PLAYING]